if you have certain types of cancer your
doctor may recommend brachytherapy also
called
internal radiation therapy
the cells in the body grow and divide as
part of the normal cell cycle the cell's
nucleus controls this process inside
each nucleus genetic material called DNA
contains the instructions for directing
this process sometimes the cell's DNA
becomes damaged normally the DNA
responds by either repairing itself or
instructing the cell to die
in cancer however the parts of the cells
DNA that direct cell division become
damaged damage to these sections
prevents DNA from repairing itself or
instructing the cell to die instead the
unrepaired DNA causes the cell to grow
and divide uncontrollably into more
damaged cells called cancer cells a
tumor forms as the cancer cells multiply
and displace the normal cells
brachytherapy treats cancer in the
following organs the breasts
the digestive system organs such as the
esophagus
and the bile duct underneath your liver
the female reproductive system organs
such as the uterus cervix
and vagina
the prostate gland in men
the rectum
the skin
the head and neck area
and the lungs
brachytherapy is a cancer treatment
where radioactive material is placed
near the cancer
depending on your procedure radioactive
wires ribbons or pellets called seeds
are placed directly into or near your
cancer tumor
the radiation from the brachytherapy
kills cancer cells by inflicting
overwhelming damage to their DNA
the tumor shrinks as the cells stop
dividing and die
the two main types of brachytherapy are
temporary and permanent if you have
temporary brachytherapy your doctor will
insert a delivery device such as a
bronchoscope to get as close to the
cancer as possible
temporary brachytherapy is usually a
high dose source of radioactive material
that will treat your cancer for several
minutes once the treatment time is over
the radiation source will be removed
if you have permanent brachytherapy your
doctor will implant radioactive seeds
that will stay in your body and emit a
low dose of continuous radiation
the seeds will get weaker over time and
gradually stop emitting radiation
brachytherapy may be used along with
external beam radiation therapy or other
cancer treatments
however the advantages of brachytherapy
over external beam radiation include a
higher more targeted dose of radiation
in a shorter period of time and less
exposure of nearby normal tissue to
radiation